reading also if you're going to put a
chunk of text before Star Wars project
you need to do it with the right color
and angle that color is mustard yellow
and that angle is toward the stars that
are apparently at War also also former
Jedi Knight I'm no Star Wars
encyclopedia but even I can hear the
frustrated Cries From outraged forums
saying that Ahsoka left the Jedi Order
before officially becoming a Jedi Knight
contradicting your own Canon before a
word of dialogue is spoken is quite
impressive even for Star Wars also
episode three Revenge of the also a
secret map you say a secret map to find
a powerful figure who hasn't been seen
in years you say I don't know everyone
sure is Awakening something familiar in
me these Republic uniforms tell me that
the in Universe team that designs them
is either hugely underpaid or hugely
doesn't give a I'm calling their
Bluff
signal them to come aboard if you don't
think they're Jedi why would you allow
them on your ship you have projector
communication systems that let you see
them use one of those letting them on
your ship just opens you up to attack or
dare I say a trap looks like we finally
have an answer to why these helmets look
so ridiculous it appears to be the
result of a budget cutting one siiz
fits-all situation the Republic can't
afford to make a helmet for every
species so they just picked the widest
head and went with that the bad guys
have already been found out but even if
they hadn't their arrival method really
didn't do them any favors not only do
they driving what looks like an imperial
shuttle in a bad disguise but they also
disembark accompanied by a dramatic
smoke machine to properly accentuate
their evilness you're no
Jedi just some overconfident Imperial
trash who just pushed their luck too far
he's got some stiff competition but this
might be the worst captain in the
Republic he knew these two weren't who
they said they were and still managed to
get completely caught off guard did the
Republic defeat the Empire and then
immediately set all systems to
complacent the Vader hallway scene is
legendary because it's dark and he
suddenly appears destroying all in his
path but this scene works for the exact
opposite reason it's well lit you can
see Balin coming and there's still
nothing you can do to stop him we see
you Ray rest in peace balen you are true
to your word and well paid for it lady
Morgan wait she seems familiar okay back
to the
internet huh looks like she popped up in
Mando season 2 wait season two how do
you expect me to remember a character I
last saw three whole years ago who is
this Jedi
Ahsoka roll title
card okay admittedly that was forcing
badass but I hope you didn't just land
on the thing you came here to find we
all love a good archaeological puzzle
but I'm pretty sure Ahsoka Jones here is
using the force to figure this out and
forgive me if listening to vague voices
in someone else's head isn't quite as
exciting as an invisible
Bridge stealthy assassin droids with
loud Flappy capes they sure are a lot of
weapons out there that negate the
advantages of lightsabers aren't there
but why do we only ever see the bad guys
using them why doesn't anyone in the
Rebellion or New Republic use stuff like
this especially when all you need to
make your weapon lightsaber proof is
some kind of crackling laser hang where
are you I am above your
position now and she didn't hear him
getting close what good is the force if
you can't use it to sensor even hear a
giant ass spaceship
arriving all right who said the
self-destruct on these Droids to
Oppenheimer I know there are three of
them but by qui-gon's beard this is a
huge ass explosion watch my back that is
the job of a Jedi Padawan learner which
I am not Padawan literally means learner
so sticking that word on the end is
redundant it's the chai tea thing all
over again also anyone can watch
ahsoka's back it doesn't have to be a
Padawan but we're clearly more invested
in trying to Parent Trap Ahsoka and
Sabine how did you get her to tell the
truth let's just say I didn't follow
standard Jedi protocol torture
euphemisms in Disney products the
location of the last missing Imperial
Grand Admiral that's not possible thron
died at the Battle of the Fall believing
this in a universe that brought back a
bifurcated Darth Maul by giving him Robo
legs if Thon survived does that mean
Ezra I hope so so elth was buddies with
thrawn and somehow found out this map in
a tomb would guide her to his location
despite the rest of the Galaxy believing
he's dead okay fine maybe she knows
something we don't but what does this
have to do with their buddy still being
alive also who the is Ezra stop leaving
me out I already feel guilty for not
watching all of Clone Wars and Rebels
you don't need to keep wailing on me
with references I don't get nothing is
certain except our enemies belief that
they know where to look that's a very
reassuring way of saying it doesn't
matter that this nonsense is nonsense
because the fact that our enemies
believe it isn't nonsense means that it
isn't nonsense the device is locked and
the key to activating it has eluded me
you know who could help you with this so
mission is hit a dead end and of course
the one person who can help her is an a
strange figure from her past hooray for
ready b Drama Lac reluctant team ups I
guess I'm not sure she'll want to help
believing that someone wouldn't want to
save an old friend and prevent the
return of an evil Galactic superpower
because of that one time you wouldn't
let them play Jedi anymore this Monument
we dedicate here today stands in
recognition of Commander Bridger and the
rebel leaders monuments to war heroes
that are more worried about being a
self-referential nod to a cartoon than
actually war hero monumen thing saine
Ren find her now hero is too cool for
your hero worship and would rather be
off racing something at dangerous speeds
instead of being celebrated as a hero
cliche Al this is a long ass completely
traffic Highway did the whole world know
she needed some free road to be mopy on
her mop head she's
crazy this stun is apparently enough to
justify this officer going from all
right look Commander I have my wife I'm
going to need you to pull over two I
guess because he respects her right to
recklessly endanger herself and one of
his colleagues showing us the entirety
of this giraffe spotted Flamingo legged
cat things dinner routine we've been
through a lot Hollow skip we're not
really
family but you're like a sister to me da
filon trying in futility to put an end
to all the Sabine Ezra shippers out
there nether the Jedi has the map where
it was vaporized great point which makes
me even more curious as to why you set
your droids to nuclear Holocaust if
keeping the map intact was the ultimate
goal luck has nothing to do with it Fate
has decided our next move Sith mantics
you were missed Sabine everyone was
there not everyone expecting president
Clancy to be able to summon the dead and
make them attend their own memorials I
think I know how to find Ezra dot dot
dot if he's alive right you see that
part is reallying important unless you
enjoy being in the building false hope
game where did you find this in a world
named
Arana it was a stronghold for the
witches of damir Arana witches this is
where Star Wars confuses the Canon out
of me okay maybe they're just reaching
for the closest English translation but
it's so distracting when Concepts that
are embedded in Earth mythology somehow
end up being used a long time ago in a
galaxy supposedly far far away I take it
these patterns of
meanings you have the artist Eye tell me
what you see I feel like there's a big
lead between being artistic and being
able to translate a squiggly Ball
created by witches thousands of years
ago well no one would design a map you
couldn't read Apple so where do you call
home these days trying to open a star
map with small talk map stays here
Sabine ignores this request but to be
fair Ahsoka didn't give her much reason
not to she could have said that a
powerful X Jedi his Padawan and several
assassin droids are chasing that map
better yet offer to go with her to
however she needs to think more clearly
so you can protect her there are a
million way ways to solve this [__]
drama tension patience this is where it
gets interesting over promising I've
been burned exactly one season of The
Book of boba had too many times to fall
for that one in the last 500 years I've
only known one student who built a saber
such as this isn't every lightsaber
unique I know the colors aren't but the
hilts are personal to the Jedi that
construct them so couldn't you say the
same thing about every single lightsaber
constructed ever master and an
apprentice okay now commercials this
highway is still empty was it
exclusively built to facilitate sabine's
urge to recklessly flip off the nearest
authority
figure snitches she took the map off the
ship when I explicitly told her not to
Anakin's Force ghost isn't in this scene
telling Ahsoka that sabina's payback for
all the time she was a little sh as a
Padawan I don't understand why things
have to be so difficult because TV and
Hollywood execs think audiences will
implode unless there's an inherent
conflict to overcome between our heroes
all I'm saying is just try it once if we
do implode then you can go right back to
the formula promise but you and I both
know sine gives you the best chance of
reading that map that sure is a damning
indictment of the Republic's scientists
and cryptographers isn't it I bet your
master found you difficult at times
Anakin never got to finish my training
ooh ooh pick me pick me I I actually
know who Anakin is yes and I didn't even
have to rely on the loaded Paws or the
suddenly apparent dramatic shift in tone
also her master found it difficult to
avoid slaughtering women and children so
maybe Anakin's restraint doesn't make
for the best example here sometimes even
the right reasons have the wrong
consequences no consequences aren't
wrong or right consequences are
consequences now your actions may have
unintended consequences but that's just
called owning your Ahsoka I'd give all
the sins back if this thing suddenly
stabbed her and summoned a slurry of
demons from hell and don't act like
sudden Hellraiser would make any less
sense than a cult of witches okay this
is it let's talk about this map an order
of witches from thousands of years ago
made a map of the Galaxy hit it in a
ball turn that ball into a Rubik sphere
buried that ball in a hole put the
answer to the puzzle on the floor above
that hole and then built a temple around
that all four why I mean clearly they
want to hide it from certain people but
the fact that they went to all this
effort and a soak and saine managed to
figure it all out in a day or two shows
the witches managed to try far too hard
and not nearly hard enough also if this
thing was buried thousands of years ago
how can it know who thrawn is look
that's such a glaring error that I'm
sure we'll get answers as the series
progresses but I have a funny feeling it
basically comes down to the forced it it
and if I'm wrong I'll write and perform
an apology song to the tune of the Star
Wars theme while juggling
lightsabers what is the point of being a
Droid if you get your ass kicked like
this you're a robot why are you acting
like that Bonk on the nogg and stuned
you we have a problem a problem that
Ahsoka predicted would happen and yet
decided to stay parked out in the
boonies instead of immediately finding
out where Sabine lives and making sure
she's safe if only you had some kind of
500-year-old armor made of a metal that
lightsabers can't cut and weapons you
were were infinitely more familiar with
than lightsabers man if
only oh wow killing off a main character
in the first episode gsy or at least
that's what I'd be thinking if I hadn't
already seen both Kyo and the third
sister get run through with a lightsaber
and survive qui-gon's Force ghost is
going to be pissed if yet another person
survives a lightsaber stabbing you are
one minute of previously on robbing us
of one minute of new Ahsoka this isn't
just about finding Ezra it's about
preventing another war is Sabine
dreaming about the previously on this
isn't just about finding Ezra Sabine is
dreaming about the previously on did you
keep a record of what you found the
droids destroyed it using the droids at
my homework as an excuse if it didn't
pass mustard and Miss McGill's math
class it's not going to work here you
can always sign me up for a good ship
Landing but we did not need nearly every
step of their walk up to this discount
stonehinge I believe we have located at
the reflex point on SOS well that seemed
really easy kind of like they just
happened to see it out of the window of
their spaceship as they flew by
definitely needed a scene about that
putting Loth cats in the willow so you
can cram your lesson about friendship
down our throats at least I'm pretty
sure that's what's going on here
cluttered work area as a sign of talent
cliche I was hoping you were still here
hoping you'll get the chance to
decapitate a Droid it's a weird thing to
get this excited about is all I'm saying
damn so hard to tell whether Ahsoka is
mad s are glad the sin is this show not
being about her absolutely dominating
the World Series of Poker take off an
arm or leg and it just keeps coming
title of my six I mean erotic I mean
familyfriendly and a no way involving
Droid being used in a manner other than
instructed fanfiction what happens if
you get the power levels wrong the head
will explode perhaps we should perform
this operation somewhere else I say go
for it there's no time to relocate show
will now make this Droid head
inexplicably explody so the hospital
scene can cosplay as if our main
characters are in danger and Ahsoka can
invoke a non-existent ticking clock
carab bass that was like three cents for
the price of one but here we do sin
counts not discounts this Droid came
here from cilia the new Republic
Shipyard episode expects me to know what
Cilia is and the new Republic and a
shipyard why does every Star Wars TV
show require so much homework also
getting all that from this wordless
display her Imperial operation should
have been dismantled after the Rebellion
anyone check on that Behold a foe more
powerful than the Empire bad project
management she doesn't want my help yes
she does is there no part of Jedi
training that focuses on the clear
Communications of thoughts and emotions
screw the force yall need therapy this
place was not built by the Jedi whose
work is it an ancient people from a
distant Galaxy answering a specific
question in the broadest terms possible
also an ancient people from a distant
Galaxy is very similar to a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away a little
too similar also also I guess it was
only a matter time before they cram Star
Wars stories inside other Star Wars
stories I was banking on a deep fried OB
Skywalk soran this is our galaxy what is
this a Galaxy for ants hologram thingy
is shooting out a laser thingy and
making the other hologram thingy do
other things excitement th call is to me
across time and space Star Wars was
becoming a convoluted mess without
forcing with time and now we're forcing
with time thanks you speak of Dreams V
fractured hopes and you speak of
dialogue from a vague and fractured
script this is starting to feel a little
too game of throny and I don't like Game
of Thrones being mixed in with my Star
Wars I mean by season 8 I didn't really
want Game of Thrones mixed in with my
Game of Thrones what happens when we
find Throne I hope it's some cool sh
because they're working hard to build
this guy up like some kind of space
anti- Jesus that's going to bring about
starmageddon and if we're being honest
as franchise jumped that shark a long
time ago with its giant space laser and
then that shark jumped another shark
while driving a Corvette Stingray when
they introduced a bigger space laser so
this end is just a warning to the series
that if you think about bringing thraw
back with an even bigger space laser
that thing better be big enough to blow
up the whole galaxy so we can get a hard
reset on this and for us power such as
you've never dreamed is someone who has
recurring dreams about break dance
fighting a centaur on the surface of the
sun while rocket by Herby Hancock plays
in the background I find this statement
to be a bit presumptuous go to kellia
assist marck with the final transport I
will stand here and stare at this hinge
for a bit then use the forced to summon
an Uber an Empire doesn't just become a
republic overnight you will still find
EX Imperials at every level of the new
republic government it's kind of wild
that this would be news to Ahsoka and
Hera like the line of here in the show
for us and not them that kind of wild I
think she could use some structure so
could you so could this show I'm curious
what makes someone ready you just know
so do they Star Wars a nebulous hope I
can't train if Ahsoka doesn't want to
teach me blaming your lack of training
on Ahsoka seems a little unfair you
should blame your lack of training on
Donuts like everyone else does Sabine
that is an excuse and a poor one who
Yang would be the wisest Droid at TV SS
she doesn't want me back she wasn't even
thinking about me if you're going to
whine like a youngling then you're going
to get treated like a young Ling so the
sin is younglings I mean kids I have
known many padawans over the centuries
and I can safely say your aptitude for
the force would fall short of them all
designing a Droid proficient in neing
well then I'm authorizing it I'm not
sure you can want to bet is this a
threat of physical harm or a threat of
staring at him until he complies one
seems illegal and the other one
shouldn't have worked for the Empire
pre-shoot yelling for the Empire like
the shooting itself would make it super
obvious that you're for the
Empire exiting through the window
instead of the door I had a friend in
college who would do this on the regular
still to this day he's an agent of chaos
whoever designed this console without
label
whether it's lightsabers or people with
superpowers it's impossible to
understand how one is more powerful than
the other but someone will win and
someone will lose and no one will care
or have any understanding of why said
winner won and why said loser lost this
Droid is just spinning around a bunch
instead of attacking great job and now
we will all pause with our weapons
interlocked for dramatic effect in a
well-deserved breather these
double-bladed lightsabers should just be
called but wait there's more Sabers this
[__] Droid is littering everywhere
reminds me of the thing about dropping
Pennies from skyscrapers when which
turns out to be much less dangerous than
dropping other things and dropping other
things is exactly what Chopper is doing
but it's cool because this Droid is the
fun friend what is that a sequencer hard
time to be working on your tracks morac
you got to get those beats in place
before the saber battle doing a risky
back flip that brings your feet closer
to the Flying blade as you rotate
instead of the more logical front flip
or just jumping straight up is every
wipe in a Star Wars a star wipe debate
no one will be seated while Sabine sets
down every single piece of her armor in
real time nice haircut we better get
moving I'm sure there's a lot of
backstory here and I get that there's
some sort of symbolism as well however
aoka has been pretty cold towards to be
this entire episode to this point you
need my help no you've done enough let's
get going no you need to recover so it
really feels like the main source of
tension between the two was her hairdo
meanwhile on Stargate for the Empire
reminding us of the for the Empire guy
one more trip down the ever cliched
Interstellar birth canal k k
making me check my language settings
while cursing the franchise for so few
of these interesting training scenes
enough to get
by barad Hey listen to your discount
Davos not every Droid in this series
needs to be in competition for the title
of Sassy one how about zi for a long
time ago in a galaxy far far away there
are certainly a lot of references to a
Japanese culture that hasn't even
existed yet your skill with a weapon
comes from your Mandalorian upbringing
those skills alone will not be enough to
defeat our enemy djar and has entered
the chat and would appreciate it if you
kept the name of his people out of
youring mouth also citing this need for
the force is the most Star Wars thing to
ever Star Wars we already have enough
Force users just let her wield
lightsabers chew bubble gum and kick ass
I can't see how am I supposed to fight
if we all know that you're supposed to
use the force here then you should know
that you're supposed to use the force
here do you know where I am next to hang
are you sure ah yes that famous power we
so rarely see the force moved to
wherever the for she needs to while the
camera is in onor I can't wait to see
Sabine master that one sense my
intention my technique for quickly
ending a first dat somehow makes its way
into the episode we have former
Imperials working throughout every level
of the new republic government and they
have all taken an oath of loyalty
Senator Rodrigo is either an imperial
loyalist as well or has never heard of
the concept of lying neither should
disqualify her from being a senator yes
but I believe their activity speaks to a
larger operation going with this instead
of saying they stole a big fing Engine
That Could be used to build a big
weapon isn't this just another attempt
to gain New Republic resources to Aid in
what has ultimately been your personal
quest to find Ezra Bridger we haven't
seen Hera be obsessed with searching for
Ezra in this series but none of these
other politic ads question zono's
assertion so he may have a point but we
have no evidence in either direction yet
in spite of that I hate this guy and
fully support Hera it's manipulation and
I fear a Sith scribe may be behind all
of this where did you hear that Chopper
told me word on the street is that
Chopper committed several war crimes you
know just things to consider before
enlisting them for babysitting Duty I
was hoping that the urgency of our
situation
could expedite my training a bit what
does that even mean and why does sine
think that that's something that could
even happen you spend five minutes on
any group project with a Jedi and you
catch job pretty quickly that this is
going to be a long drawn out process
with no distinct beginning or end
they're not even sure what the goal is
half the time how do you expect them to
expedite it Talent is a factor but
training and focus are what truly Define
someone's success that is a lesson for
the kids and any adults whose spirit is
not yet broken so the sin is just the
kids because the latter do not exist the
Jedi Order would not have accepted her
she is not an acceptable candidate by
their standards standards which were
proven over a millennia and failed and
fail doesn't quite capture being
overthrown by the most obviously evil
dude hiding in plain sight and a whiny
kid with daddy issues I suppose you do
come from a long line of non-traditional
Jedi and if you don't get what that
means stop the show here and go watch a
100 70 hours of previous Star Wars
content to catch up don't worry we'll
wait mocking me for the thing I do at
least three times a day to test my own
Force sensitivity the difference is when
Sabine does IT staff doesn't throw
pencils at her and shall get back to
work we've entered the den app system
all com Transmissions are being drowned
all the Comm transmissions for the
entire system while in a hyperspace Lane
is it possible maybe is it convenient
radio FY definitely why' we drop out of
hyperspace so far from the planet well
Productions cooked up a cool space
battle to spice up this procedural
walkthrough of a plot standard Jedi
Mission protocol When approaching an
unknown situation you say malur run I
say Mal run it's getting us in either
way over price C3PO tell them please it
took three episodes for the series to
finally show us its ball turret I see
you got rid of my presets I never needed
them come on no one ever deletes presets
leave them there to languish for an
eternity and a Restless Slumber this is
so much like a World War II air battle
that it doesn't feel like space at all
is there air we don't know lucky or
unlucky for Sabine all the fighters seem
dead set on flying directly at the tail
Gunner position feast or famine am I
right the way you're both acting there
won't be a lat oh relax hang this is
only episode three you can panic when
they're still doing this by episode
seven or
eight Dive Dive as a directional command
makes very little sense in space and is
not nearly as sexy as change orientation
with a 90° pitch down maneuver using a
propulsive burn we got two more incoming
dead ahead and given the fact that no
forward weapons are fired I guess this
ship has no front guns and given the
fact that these Fighters hit absolutely
nothing I guess they're former Storm
Troopers W I got one and murder is fun
hey scene why are you being this way I
am starting to receive data title of my
TX tape how interesting I would never
have guessed that oh pray tell I'm on
the edge of my seat and we'll remain so
until I get all the hot gas I'm sure the
show wouldn't make me wait another 8
minutes for the hot goas deflectors at
10% using math to tell me the situation
is dire scan
complete destroyed well get the force
out of here with this brief moment of
did the title character just die in
episode three just force right off with
that ban Thea [__] this ship is
damaged and not moving they don't need
to keep flying by so fast like that pump
the brakes and line up your shot also
can Ahsoka even get The High Ground in
outer space damn prequel memes
subreddits have ruined
me
well that was pretty freaking cool go
ahead take your sim back a lot of effort
was just put into trying to kill a sooka
instead of blowing up the ship and that
made no sense forget about the Eagles I
want to know why they didn't fly the
Perle to Mordor just kidding I know this
isn't Harry Potter I've got an opening
we all do Everybody Poops they must be
hiding in the forest let's regroup
episode takes the idea of scanning for
life forms or heat signatures out of its
pocket and looks at it fondly for a
second and then throws it out of the car
onto the highway just like I did with my
brother's baseball glove when I was five
a craft with these power levels and
configuration would be capable of a
hyperspace jump of astonishing speed and
distance episode uses astonishing speed
and distance like it's worried about
kessle running itself into a corner the
Jedi archives speak of Intergalactic
hyperspace Lanes between galaxies which
used to follow the migration Paths of
star whales named Perle Droid explaining
your Jedi arives position Jedi have
taken refuge in the forest hunt them
down I'm going to keep staring at this h
because rocks man how do they work what
did I miss I mean every week I'm hoping
it's the previously on segments but they
just keeping running them come in home
one this is fulker repeat do you read us
over allow me to reiterate how
nonsensical it is or at least the
internet tells me for subbe to be using
a rebel erera code name the Empire is
already more than aware of thanks to
thrawn and agent callus and if you won't
allow me to reiterate then C can just do
it if we can't make the journey to find
Ezra then no one should that is Far and
Away the creep if I can't have him you
can't either I've ever heard he'd be
stranded out there maybe this time for
good better that than allowing thon's
return as heir to the Empire but Thon
could Escape even if just sa and Ahsoka
triy to go get Ezra so if Ahsoka is this
concerned about Thon and willing to
leave Ezra out there forever already
then why isn't the plan to just destroy
the map ball and move on with their
lives Ezra free also thinking that name
dropping the best Star Wars novel will
make me forget how Disney uncanonized
the expanded universe and replac it with
things like The Last Jedi and Rise of
Skywalk Walker I did not forget and I
did not forgive s Ahsoka doing that
thing your mom does when she waits for
you to walk away before telling you to
do something else
Master we received word better than
receiving Excel or access I
guess I thought it was
funny how can ahok sine not hear this
the door to the ship is open literally
sounds like pots and pans having an orgy
in
there that death Droid made it worse
first of all rude second of all you
crash landed an enemy territory after
being shot down and this is your first
thought you'll thank me they will not
I'm not just going to sit around and do
nothing with him I've heard that there
are four seasons of Star Wars Rebels
that at least on occasion tell a very
different version of that statement but
but you can't believe without
authorization Lieutenant wants the
audience to be shocked that one of the
characters on a show called Rebels is
now rebelling how come I to do it I'm
told you don't I'm not sure but what's
more concerning is that Hara is bringing
her child on this very dangerous Mission
thanks for joining the party Carson
wouldn't miss it General name dropping
this random officer means that I should
already know who he is and what other
Star Wars related material I've seen him
in but I shouldn't have to know who he
is to understand a scene quit pulling
this crap Ahsoka I'm actually at times
not having a horrible time with your
show man just have to get those words
out have faith faith I lost that a long
time ago no I think if you're getting
that confused with the inability to have
an erection without the aid of a pill or
a viewing of a lightsaber battle they're
easily confused I keep hoping that this
ball will turn into a fantasm ball and
Blades will come out of it that will
then Lodge in people's foreheads and
kill them I have weird desires like the
desire to not have to remember who
Carson is witchcraft sure Balin because
as history has taught us immediately
assuming someone's involved in
witchcraft always ends well and no one
gets set on fire or hung from the
rafters and then said things that never
happened wouldn't also inspire a
playright to create a 16th century set
play about whiches that was in fact a
direct metaphor for the McCarthy
hearings in the Red Scare that would
never
happen cardio also I can't think of a
worse thing to do before a big battle
than Sprint for a full click click and a
half I don't know how clicks work let me
first shed my cloak so you'll know that
I'm very serious about this upcoming
lightsaber battle because otherwise you
might think I'm only partially invested
in these festivities you know my
favorite part of lightsaber battles it's
when they walk around in a circle and
stare into each other's eyes I mean who
needs actual light lights saering in a
lightsaber battle when you have staring
and circular
stepping you see weeks of rampant
speculation about morac secretly being
Ezra or some other Padawan only to have
it revealed he's nothing more than
excess gas in a suit I'm just saying I
didn't expect that morac could have just
been defeated by a Pepto-Bismol chewable
you will regret this decision I mean
it's nowhere near the worst decision sub
makes in this episode so probably not he
never mentioned you well you see Ahsoka
that's because while you may have a
15-year-old history they need to invent
a mysterious new antagonist for your
show that they could say has always been
in a galaxy far far away it's an Nifty
little trick The Writer's use called
Vader's dead and we need a new villain
before kylo shows up and you find
starting another War necessary I'm not
starting a war but thraw will and you're
going after Thon so he can start the war
so you're not exactly innocent in the
whole starting a war thing Balin one
Must Destroy in order to create spoken
like a toddler with a crayon and a
perfectly white wall I King love this
duel they don't just run in swinging
like crazy and screaming you can feel
the tension they're building between
Ahsoka and Balon as they size each other
up for a bit kind of feels like an
original trilogy duel and hot damn is
that a relief after the last season am
Mando once in all for a promising fight
to come the Jedi has engaged Lord BM at
the H how long until we receive the
final coordinates moments moments of
convenience also how does he not know
exactly is the download rapidly
switching the time remaining between 3
minutes and 3 days throwing stones and
laser created map
houses why fight so hard to get a little
metal ball if you wanted to lay Morgan
just destroy the transmitter beaming
coordinates to her ship look at this
giant middle box that'd be way easier to
destroy than grabbing the map Source in
the middle of a fight you have no power
are you sure because she's doing the
hand thing usually the hand thing means
you have power I'm just saying maybe you
give the hand thing a little more time
to work before making such a declarative
statement your legacy like your Masters
was one of death and destruction was
there a scene of a a slaughtering
children I missed because I'm pretty
sure she's killed the least number of
people in the Galaxy dumb line is
dumb I don't know why Jedi don't use the
force all the time I it wouldn't make
for great TV I get that but throwing
[__] into rocks would be my opening
move my finishing move and my middle
move and I might sprinkle in a ripping
of someone's spine out of their body
what does it make them tired only grou
looks tired when he uses it and he's a
baby is there a meter so we can see the
degrees of force each Jedi has left
would that make this more like a video
game
yes is this already too much like a
video game also yes I get her hand is
hurting but Ahsoka dual wields
lightsabers all the time which means she
should be better equipped at fighting
one-handed more than just about anyone
it didn't need to come to this when you
know no other way well isn't this the
pot calling the other lightsaber
lightsaber I'd be more worried if Star
Wars didn't have a history of bringing
people back after they've fallen from a
great height Star Wars is becoming the
boy who cried dead Jedi and I don't like
it your family died on Mandalore because
your m I didn't trust you wait no
Wikipedia tells me that Ahsoka had
nothing to do with sabine's parents
dying that was all MF Gideon in the
night of a thousand tears and we haven't
been given a flashback before now that
establishes otherwise why is this
exchange Lord B has remedied the
situation calculations are complete
already that was like half a second
after he established the connection how
did they not already have the
calculations when the map field was
disrupted yes yes yes affirmative this
is V I thought Morgan was jamming comms
did that just stop once y yangang fix
the radio why would Morgan allow
Communications to suddenly resume no one
will be following us except for the ex
Jedi who Indiana Jones the map into her
hand but other than her yeah no one's
going to be following you I I've got a
bad feeling well you should have taken
care of that before you left Hara warned
you there were no rest stops in this
system Jason oh wow I can't believe
they're using this place in the
liveaction series that I absolutely
recognize and is super duper meaningful
to me I loved it from that one cartoon
where they did the cartoon stuff hooray
for call backs that we all very much get
and aren't frustrated by at
all master maybe she thinks this is the
young Anakin who trained her and I'm
sure she still has great memories
attached to that Anakin however it still
feels like this franchise is trying to
rehabilitate a serial killer who killed
fing children I'll never be able to get
past that nor should I have to footage
doesn't contain narration from Sir David
atenor for a device that was pierced by
a tube shaped lava substance thing this
star map sure looks like it was sliced
rather than saber skewed I'm sorry but
the regular task of speaking into your
cstick would demand the necessity of a
pocket perfectly placed for such a thing
no use to risk losing it in the folds of
your front clothes like that Mom can I
come out now no you cannot come out now
your mom will ping you on the comms when
it's time stay inside where you're safe
for sake this is why you never take
children on dangerous secret
missions all right yeah sure you've
taken seven steps and swiveled your head
twice I'm sure that's an in-depth enough
search to determine your son is safe we
don't know this planet so keep chopper
with you continuing to allow the biggest
war criminal in a galaxy far far away to
babysit your son putting the zipper on
the back instead of the front I told
them to stay together but they never
listen you don't know they're not
together though you were at the ship
when they split up and Ahsoka fell over
the side all you know is San left her
helmet behind there's no evidence to
suggest Ahsoka and saine split up from
your point of view did you read this
script hang you look the same he does
not I'm here to finish your training but
only as long as it takes for your body
to be recovered from under water just
before drowning so let's hop right to it
one is never too old to learn Snips Matt
Lanter isn't the one calling her Snips
in this scene I won't fight you I've
heard that before pointing out that
we've heard something before to make us
feel all the good nostalgic feelings
while simultaneously feeling the
confusion of being excited for another
moment when anak canor Force fights his
Protege I'll cover it but good is a
higher rank if you can't use it every
now and then if you could cover it why
don't you just start with doing that
when the dumbest senator's known to man
declined to give you the requested
resources seems like a movie should have
led with Jason has abilities his father
Kanan jarus was a Jedi all the more
reason why Ahsoka should be training
Jason instead of Sabine looks like you
don't have much left to offer getting
cocky when you landed exactly one blow
on the guy the internet tells me Vader
killed you so good last time that Dave
filon had to introduce fing time travel
to the Star Wars Universe just to bring
you back you're going to show me this
fing badass flash back and make me
believe that Ahsoka decided to abandon
this sweet headpiece sometime in the
future impossible no one could say say
goodbye to that look at it this is the
CL War uh sure yep I knew that we'd
suddenly found our way into another TV
show altogether totally knew that before
blatantly being told about it why are we
here you tell me ah I see we've
immediately jumped from the teacher
having one big lesson to teach to you
must teach yourself without skipping a
beat they were following my orders I got
them killed you're 14 if someone put you
in charge it's their
[Music]
fault okay
that's an incredible visual we're going
to press our fuel reserves if I have to
hear about fuel in a Star Wars property
one more time I'm going to stop sinning
this all together actually we both know
that's a lie but I will hit you with 5
cents for this annoying carryover from
The Last Jedi you do things your way
because you can this is the same Droid
that gave aoka for doing things the
non-jedi way but is clearly capable of
comforting a rogue general what an ass
people don't just vanish Into Thin Air
in this world they actually do what was
he like listen if there's any sort of
backstory that we need to know it's how
the general here either doesn't know
anything about ahsoka's master or knows
the name but has no historical
understanding of who Anakin is or what
he became this is the sort of detail to
dig into cut out the previous Leons and
give me a few minutes of perspective on
Hera intense choosing to describe Anakin
or is anything other than murderous or
conflicted by sand Chopper says you're
going to have to get low somehow the
Droid on the high high Cliffs picks up
something in the low low waters before
anyone else and I'm beginning to wonder
if all the equipment everyone has is
really just for [__]
and this is why you cannot give
lightsabers to children show ruins a
chance for a perfectly clear hero stance
desktop background with a dramatic Smoky
sand filter I gave you a choice
live or die bro can't go 5 minutes
without trying to murder a child can he
also I'm not sure what lesson Anakin is
trying to teach Ahsoka here but I'm
pretty sure it's related to fanfiction
demands for a Vader Ahsoka standoff more
than a need for character
development
ah stop it I can only change my pants so
many times we got her
CH Jason doesn't react to whatever
smartass remark I'm sure Chopper just
made sleeping with your head at a 90°
angle this is terrible for your spine
who cares that you're not human
vertebral health is important for any
species wearing your bed sheet will you
train me no will you teach me no I don't
think they're coming to
help programming your Droid for
maximum these space whales have
essentially become the Star Wars
equivalent of the Eagles from Lord of
the Rings the Senate oversight committee
is going to determine if your command
should be permanently suspended wow
that's quite a waste of time with that
level of incompetence the first order
could take things back over in a decade
or twoh get your together I don't know
how you score this but we're losing
right now so then why not pick up the
hollow puck in your hand while she's
talking and at least have some fun with
how it's all projected I mean pop her in
your shoe or have her dangling from the
dash upside down make the lost to a
flickering image fun before you're out
of a job I know how to follow Sabine and
in just a few minutes she will admit
that she actually does not if you would
have told me that the symbolic moment of
ahsoka's Resurrection would be
punctuated by Jonah style hyperdrive
space whales not have told you to stop
eating unregulated gummies wish me luck
hang doesn't wish your sooka luck what a
dick ap5 would have wished Ahsoka good
luck behold Ahsoka in her savior era she
flies she speaks with animals she was
dead once she wears white cue the clouds
in sunlight for Star Wars Gandalf they
can't interrupt they frighten the Pod
the fleet will frighten the Pod the same
Fleet that the Pod cruises through
without so much as a reaction here in a
few minutes you mean that pod Captain
the reason we are here is because there
was no Mission that's not true there was
a mission it just wasn't sanctioned and
while I'm at it what parameters did Hera
violate the X-Wing Pilots came of their
own accord and she didn't use New
Republic resources she came in the ghost
which is her personal ship I'm not
seeing any rules broken show just wants
to generate tension to drag out the
runtime I just want to peek into the
world where these folks get fit for
their uniforms it seems like there'd be
some interesting conversations about how
the leg section needs a few more slouch
folds okay but you're not going to
believe me well not with that attitude
she won't sorry kid you don't get
gumdrops on your badge you get a vent
covered by a piece of cardboard move us
in aren't you supposed to flee to Tarsus
before you get inside the whale I think
you missed a few steps here Ahsoka
evasive maneuvers they clear up their
path wow not since Han listed lazily to
the left have I seen such effective
evasive
maneuvers
oh sh nobody warned me the episode would
start like this hold on pause it I need
to go grab my Edibles and turn on Dark
Side of the Moon I am history of the
Galaxy Parts one two and three one being
the best of course what's more
distracting than Ahsoka basically
looking into the camera as she said this
is that she could theoretically be
talking about The Phantom Menace or a
new hope you she could totally be
talking about The Phantom Menace she
could have ended this no Throne no war
don't worry Ahsoka even if she had ended
this you'd still have more war when the
first order came along a few decades
later when War's 50% of your title
you're pretty much always guaranteed to
have it a long time ago in a galaxy far
far away cliche we had a deal you
promised me I would see Ezra again no
part of that deal specifies how you'd be
transported to Ezra got to be smarter
with your bargain sub beine if reading
Dresden Files has taught me anything
it's that wording in your Bargains is
extremely
important JJ Abrams called he wants his
space effects back I got confused for a
minute trying to remember whether it was
Lady Morgan or Chris Pine that was
captaining the ship Soo was all like we
hear the complaints about all the other
Star Wars shows having too much Tatooine
and sand so we're not going to do that
but we will make sure everying planet
has a stonehinge enjoy oh goody Star
Wars version of deadites we've already
seen their version of Star Trek space
whales star Gates and fantasm balls in
this series might as well keep ripping
off as many other properties as possible
your Visions guided me across the Stars
they didn't not you had a fantasm ball
map and a weird Stargate ship which
we've already covered keep up El Beth
where is thrawn you shall wait he is
coming yeah we've been told that for
fiveing episodes I'm really un tired of
being told to wait why don't youing wait
for one see how you like
that wait I'm sorry what was
that that would just add episodes huh
never mind we'll go at your pace Ahsoka
but I don't fing like it it reeks of die
the sisters pick up on the can't even
lift a mug with the force Jedi adjacent
odor of Sabine instead of the literally
trained as a Jedi for years and even has
a master and Apprentice Dynamic odor of
Balin and shin it is dangerous seriously
discout cinnabites do you back anything
up or are you just accusing people
randomly because I get enough of that
reading correspondences in the sin's
mail room which also weirdly has a stone
hinge this is a land of dreams and
Madness David Lynch is Ahsoka children's
stories come to life Tim Burton's Ahsoka
stories of this galaxy are considered
folktales in a universe of force Powers
witches light speed travel and aliens of
all types I'm curious what the criteria
for being a folk tail is where's the
line of believability it's the only
problem with having a universe with all
these fantastic things in it well not
the only problem there's also the book
of Boba Fett when I was a bit older than
you are now I watched everything I knew
burn I'd like to go ahead and burn all
of my skips and go ahead and use them
here because I don't care as you get
older look at history you realize it's
all inevitable I fuing love everything
about Balin his relationship with Shin
is so respectful and caring his clear
torment from surviving Order 66 is
readily apparent in all of his
Expressions he really is the Charles
Dance of the show so I'm sending the
universe for taking him away so soon
fall of the Jedi rise of the empire it
repeats again and
again again reason many critics haven't
liked a Star Wars property since Return
of the Jedi makes its way into into this
episode why wasn't thrawn's ship here
and ready when Morgan arrived seems like
they had plenty of notice between when
she popped out of hyperspace and when
she landed on this spire better yet if
these night sisters read the future
shouldn't they have been able to tell
thraw exactly when they would
[Music]
arrive
thraw me there are movies that don't
look anywhere near this good everything
from the weathered stormtrooper armor to
the Star Destroyer repaired with golden
lines in a kugi style to this epic
entrance of a villain that has been
hyped in books cartoons and now live
action is just mindblowing take a sin
back while I go change my pants but with
that being said I don't know why Thon
looks like a perfect blend of Robert
Patrick and Elon Musk I understand it is
you I have to thank for my escape from
Exile I mean not really all she really
did was refuse to destroy the orb Shin
had already retrieved from Morgan and
Balin I wouldn't call that helping as
much as refusing to hinder if you
survived I'm sure he's doing just fine
you've GBL the fate of your Galaxy on
that
and it is supered up that Sabine did
this and maybe I'll be wrong and she'll
have to pay dearly for the storm she's
brought down on everyone but there
wasn't a way to make all of these things
happen without us having to hate the out
of
Sabine bat dog die well s can die
however she wants thank you very much
man even in Star Wars women are told
what to do with their
bodies having the drop and a clear shot
on your Target and choosing to shoot her
Nintendo switch instead of her head
where the was this Sabine during the
earlier fight with Shen feel like Shen
would have lost both duels if this
Sabine fought them our primary objective
is to escape this galaxy I didn't come
into Ahsoka thinking thon's intentions
will be very similar to kangs and Antman
quantam Mania but here we are it matters
not whether Ren and Brit are killed or
stranded here if it doesn't matter then
why bother sending anyone after them at
all just keep all your guards here to
play defense in case they attack and if
they don't it's moot my man you you aand
me assuming TOA knows how to speak
English also sine asked for a ride and
not a bodyguard so her irritation to TOA
for not fighting with her seems a little
unfair and therefore
sinful you got something going from you
for being a coward to I trust you
completely and will follow your every
lead is a choice you were thirsty well
no sh Sabine he's been carrying your
armored ass for hours you'd be thirsty
too hey Frank I think I got an idea for
a new creature for the show oh yeah M
what is it well what if you had a
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle but it had
weird long alien eyes and came up like a
mushroom person in Super Mario Bros
that's why they pay you the big bucks M
you steal all your ideas from the best
sources Ezra do do you do you know Ezra
saine has been riding for a few hours
and comes across a single alien who not
only knows who Ezra is but can lead her
to him and if that wasn't unbelievable
enough we later learned that these crap
people are migratory so all that to say
this works comes from a breed of boken
Jedi trained in the wild after the
temple fell the heck is a boken Jedi
turns out there are more flavors of Jedi
than there are types of apples but show
doesn't realize that much like apples
I'm only interested in the red and green
ones Star Wars creates adorable alien
baby cliche I knew I could count on you
were you counting on her to find you
because my understanding is that the
conclusion of rebels made it seem like
you were counting on her to protect
lethal in your absence I just want to be
happy that I found you okay but
betraying a Sook and subsequently
guaranteeing the return of the most
dangerous Empire figurehead post Vader
is kind of something you don't just get
to gloss over for a happy moment
especially when you just undercut the
importance of Ezra's sacrifice at the
Battle of lethal the thread of Fate has
spoken to us another comes a Jedi well
your threat of Fate is some [__]
because Ahsoka isn't a Jedi anymore just
like Balon isn't a Jedi anymore do you
even know what a Jedi looks like or do
you just accuse everyone you see of
being one and hope you'll eventually be
right I want to know how backgrounds
history her world her master everything
you already know her master you met
Anakin during the Clone Wars bro did you
forget
that 19 seconds into the previously
awning you show previously on what was
previous to the previously on if not the
previously awning see it's confusing
telling me that this is course on in the
previously on instead of putting it in
giant letters on my screen for me to
read you know so I can send you for
reading this report reads like a child's
fairy tale Jedi false Jedi star Maps
star whales distant galaxies honestly
are we to believe any of it I mention
this is exactly what people who didn't
watch Rebel said upon starting Ahsoka
it's me I'm people also all those listed
things are real and witnessed by more
people than just Hera except false Jedi
I agree that's a madeup [__] Morgan
eleth was leading a coordinated effort
by the Imperial Remnant objection you
can't object you're the judge you've got
a bang something to maintain order what
about the conflict on Mandalore I
understood that reference ah yes I love
having to watch seven different things
to stay up to date on a Show's lore
really makes it all worth it creier but
why are you here I assume it's because
they ran out of cartoon characters at
Cameo apparently if this series Falls
below three cameos per episode the bus
will explode I am here on behalf of
Senator Leia Orana whoa see 3bo and a
Leia name drop this is really still not
enough to salvage this scene from Droid
in order for me sorry I object in the
strongest terms it's weird how no one
else is talking on the council probably
to save Disney money but it gives the
effect that no one really gives a sh
about this besides the guy we're
supposed to hate the court cannot admit
evidence of this kind from a mere Droid
M Droid mere Droid sir you were in the
presence of one Anthony Daniels and if
he dragged his 77-year-old ass down to
your stupid little hearing you will
treat him with more respect here's three
sins for your Outburst pray I do not
alter the sins any further blink blink
blink blink
blink
they made 20 or more of these recordings
well that's a convenient way to Cameo
Hayden Christensen whenever people get
bored and the show needs to pick me up
show once again teases me with seven
lightsabers in storage that we have no
information about are they from slain
Jedi inquisitors a BOGO deal from Bed
Bath and Beyond are they scented to
match each season I need answers Ahsoka
well you should have said something I
did but you never [__] with your
Droid for fun and not in a fanfiction
way it's an imperial mindfield deploy
around the arrival Point how much time
pass between the witches telling thraw
Ahsoka was coming in now because I'm
having trouble believing it' be enough
time to set up such an elaborate trap
and now the ship will dive into a ring
of spacecraft so dense it's impossible
to see through and because nothing is
explained we're forced to assume that a
combination of luck the force a
well-built ship and maybe a force field
Shield thing or the only reason they
survived this Grand Admiral as you
anticipated the Minefield was triggered
by a PO variety starws [__] he
predicted that the witches did all the
predicting damn even in a g Far Far Away
women still can't get credit for their
own work what a shame the master was
General Anakin
Skywalker you could actually see and
hear the oh sh in his voice I'm so glad
they brought Lars melson back to play
thron because he's perfect in the role
go ahead and take a in off while I'm in
a good mood but don't expect that good
mood to last because I just finished
eating my Taco Bell and things go
downhill pretty fast after that being
this confident that your four massive
ink bins aren't going to ruin your white
suit this is why pocket protectors exist
people without Pursuit we shall lose
them in the debris field stop saying
debris field I do not like this how did
they anticipate our arrival ahoka
already told you they took Sabine surely
robot as smart as yourself could predict
they'd take precautions in case saine's
Master pursued them huh not all the
places I expected Star Wars to pull
inspiration from the Oregon Trail wasn't
one of them hope Ezra doesn't get denter
and die or do I damn it Star Wars no
more little green babies my heart can
only take so much Emperor died don't
worry he'll probably return somehow how
did you
what fun you never said it's complicated
it's really not that complicated you
betrayed your master and undid asra
Sacrifice by siding with his greatest
enemy there see not complicated yeah so
where is Ahsoka is she
coming that's complicated just say your
Jedi Master was killed and you absconded
with her murderer it's not that
complicated great mother this I'm in
need of your assistance you going to
give them credit for their help this
time or you going to steal that too why
are you chanting you don't have a flying
laser pointer you're not one part of
this so stop trying to be in their click
something happened what was it I don't
know feeling you don't know you
literally just said ahsoka's name Tano
Ren whom we have wisely sent far from
here if you already knew you weren't her
Target then what was the purpose of
flushing her out of hiding she was
always going to puru sine instead of
attacking you so what did you gain by
tracking her in the debris with the
witches other than adding a few more
minutes in this episode's run time you
won't help your ambition drives you in
One
Direction my path lies in another as far
as excuses for abandoning someone goes I
think I prefer going out for cigarettes
using these lame ass ships instead of
the Tie fighters we can see you have
them I want to hear
[Music]
my sounds how dare you deprive me it's
my favorite noise in Star Wars aside
from the guitar bombs the fets
[Music]
use cute little alien reacts toing up in
a Star Wars property cliche can't
I'm going to circle up trying to prove
your a space Western by stealing from
actual westerns this entire sequence
just screams gunm smoker rawh hide and
if you're confused by those references
ask your grandpa as soon as he wakes up
from his nap to eat dinner at 400 p.m.
[__] W Ezra is not immediately shot in
the head after leaving the safety of his
minimal cover to wopa wopa in this scene
hang on a few seconds ago Thon said not
to prepare defenses for Ahsoka and she
was just after sub Bean so why are these
ships still chasing her man to be an
enemy pilot in the Star Wars Universe
just you and the Open Sky and all of the
Starships you can miss on my mark turn
these stairs into a ramp for no reason
thanks well now this is a surprise that
she landed in the one spot where you
were out of all the possible Landing
sites I agree that is a surprise and a
sinw worthy one at that the length of
her sweater Poncho in relation to her
lightsabers makes me wonder how often
Jedi have to explain their singed
clothing to the tailor two lightsabers
take it you keep it fing what she
traveled to an entirely different galaxy
to return that to you and you just no
thanks this makes about as much sense as
Luke throwing away his old lightsaber
the ray brought him take youring laser
sword and cut people up that's what we
came here to see no the force is my Ally
that's all I need I'm going to call
[__] on that and if I see you using
anything but the force in this fight I'm
going to order 66 sins just for you
every fight with Sabine is now just a
waiting game to see how long before she
loses both her blasters and has to pull
out the lightsaber it's not looking good
for you I don't know dude I'd argue at
taking the two of you to to make one
passable Jedi and hold her off isn't all
that great of a look
either okay now do that to Sabine it'll
be easy what are you waiting for
cooldowns or something can't defeat
mea's Wikipedia summary tells me she
survived fighting Vader dude I think she
could take you if she didn't have a
scorched hand or runtime constraints you
mean to tell me that stupid ship has had
Rockets this entire time well I guess
when you have the worst fighter pilots
in the Galaxy on your tail why waste the
ammunition kind of seems like you should
have used that weapon before now do they
not have a choosing the right weapon 101
class at Jedi Academy destroy them wait
wait wait and then they do despite being
given orders by Shin they obey Ezra and
hear him out long enough for the rescue
to be perfectly
timed
deasa oh look it's Mr the forces my Ally
what happened did you run out of force
do you wish you had a lightsaber right
about now I told you what would happen
if I saw you using another weapon as ra
you brought this on
[Music]
yourself there San goes again hoarding
rocket darts M the pizza rolls are
almost done guys getting a feeling hey
so am I all warm and fuzzy it feels
weird but kind of nice this is exactly
how I'd want to feel in a series with
wait how many episodes are left one they
wasted how many episodes to get here I
think I might be going home after all no
don't say that that's like the old
police Sergeant who says he's just one
day away from retirement I have a
feeling fans will Riot if Ezra dies ah
who am I kidding they'll r no matter
what no one hates Star Wars more than a
Star Wars fan listen on this occasion
I'm only sending the previous Leons
because this episode's 46 minute run
time hardly seems long enough to wrap
everything up especially when I'm hoping
30 of those minutes are just dedicated
to Balin slow combing his beard is it
just me or does this shot managed to be
phallic yonic and sexually penetrative
all at once just me liar granddad
Admiral the cargo transfer is complete
thank goodness I've been waiting so long
for them to finish with this cargo
transfer it's eating up like 30% of The
Season's plot I can't wait for the
payoff that'll come from showing me
what's inside those boxes you're not
going to show me what's inside those
boxes are you come on what's in the
box there is little the Jedi can do to
stop us now yeah but you only know that
because Darth Fon already announced he's
making a movie to tie up the new
Republic shows I don't care if you're a
witch reading the script is cheating she
who heard out dreams across the stars
all right so back in episode one I send
the Magic Orb knowing where thrawn is
and this is what I said I have a funny
feeling it basically comes down to the
force did it and if I'm wrong I'll write
and perform an apology song to the tune
of the Star Wars theme while juggling
lightsabers well it's clearly because of
some witchy powers and not the force and
as I'm a man of my word I present to you
my apology with lightsaber
juggling I am so very
sorry so very very
sorry
sorry oh
my huh it does cauterize the whole thing
the
blade TS you know what Jo I am done
going to Wikipedia to understand
references to cartoons and books from
the last few years I will instead reward
you with our own patented blade of talin
okay this might be one of the wittiest
episode titles in the history of episode
titling makes sense for the story the
syllables lineup hell wardrobe and
warlord even start the same but did
someone forget that we're dealing with
some serious Galaxy threatening sh here
a witty pun is not the shift in tone I
was expecting the blade emitter is too
narrow ha haa people complain the
lightsabers were too skinny in the
cartoon very funny self-aware reference
just build your damn lightsaber also I
didn't have Disney adapts Galaxy's Edge
build a lightsaber Workshop into a live
action scene on my sin card but here we
are what happened between those two save
your breath Ezra we've been wanting to
know the same thing all season but it
doesn't look like ahoka became afraid
that saine was training as a Jedi for
the wrong reasons after what happened on
Mandalore oh so you're telling him did
no one think that crucial bit of
backstory might have helped us
understand their relationship a bit more
also Ahsoka felt her Padawan might risk
falling to the dark side and just
decided to stop training her makes sense
I mean can you imagine if sine just woke
up to find her master trying to kill her
she slept that'd be so ridiculous and
out of
character
your gamble paid off hold your forces
there Ahsoka you can't claim the gamble
has paid off until all the holographic
cards have been revealed if thw makes it
back to your Galaxy that is the very
definition of the gamble not paying off
so you know no she just took a trip on a
space wheel to another galaxy because
some other witch got their hands on a
one-of aind mat ball that was given to
them by one of ahsoka's other former
padle yes of course youing knew you
didn't destroy the orb sorry are you
though you didn't trip over your armor
fumbled that ball into bal's hands that
was definite and considered choice you
made Choice I'm pretty confident you'd
make again Own It sine own the fact that
you possibly wreck the Galaxy mere years
after it freed itself oh that over the
years I've made my share of difficult
choices yeah but did any of those
choices ever risk bringing back the
greatest threat to peace in the Galaxy
often no one understood my
reasons accept my master Anakin using
Anakin as your benchmark for rational
decision making is a choice being a
Jedi isn't about wielding a light
superer oh you're funny Star Wars I
almost think you mean that sorry sorry
sorry sorry no no no no no seriously say
it again say it again I can keep a
straight face this time being a
Jedi isn't about wielding a light
superer hey let's go just finished
exactly in time to see Tha Tie fighters
conveniently arrive if is how I think he
wanted to finish that
sentence I know the fighters technically
hit the engines but this ship is an
absolute tiptoeing Sitting Duck and they
had all of the runup to get these shots
in this quarterback should be toast and
on the second run they miss it entirely
the very least the first starting run
should have been to get your eye on the
target so you can lock in and obliterate
that on the return run have these guys
never played Star Wars TIE
[Music]
fighter I really don't know how we can
ever take the Empire seriously when the
insanely maneuverable Tie fighters are
piloted by dumb asses that think
covering their helmeted faces as they
fly directly into the enemy is their
best course of
action ahus t61 974 survives this hm I
really should have given that a sexier
name or at least something easier to say
like Sith Slayer or the indat indee in
inder in defer you know what t61 974 is
totally f fine sorry to State the
obvious but this is going to slow us
down a bit I mean it can't slow you down
any more than traveling with the space
crabs right how fast were you're going
like 3 mph my pug runs faster than that
when I'm popping popcorn only if we let
it which is ahsoka's way of saying those
now defenseless Turtle Gremlins we've
befriended let's leave them utterly
stranded and open to attack as we Gallop
towards our ticket home consider all of
the Tie fighters lost Mark that Captain
for a citation I hope that citation is
for Trooper most likely to disappoint
the Empire by being a dumbass in the
face of underwhelming odds their options
to prevent that departure are now
severely limited if not impossible
typical Star Wars villain underestimates
the good guys instead which is why we
should prepare for a ground assault oh
kind of took the wind out of my sales
there thrwy wait is this an intelligent
Star Wars villain what that's not my
Star Wars now we have a phallic Tower of
magic entering a yonic symbol of fascism
which is also being docked by ionic
piece of technology and please tell me
I'm still not the only one seeing this
The Rock lizards from a far far away
Galaxy are able to make sense of the
strange technology on this ship and help
Huang repair it while I still burn my
toast every morning Tron found this
place woke up the witches rebuilt his
Starship I don't think we can overstate
how lucky Thon he got he landed on a
planet that just happened to be
inhabited by exiled witches who not only
had knowledge of a map to this galaxy
but also had access to a sister witch
working for the Empire who could help
them it's amazing he landed on a planet
with life on it at all also are we
really going to just skip over how he
woke up the great mothers were they dead
in stasis we could have had an entire
episode dedicated to thraw finding this
Ancient Temple braving the catacombs and
waking up these magical beings instead
it's brushed over in a single sentence
rain Hellfire upon them this really
should have worked like really this is a
star destroyer unleashing Fury against
three squishy people and Thon knows
exactly where they're heading yes
they're using the forcex mocking it a
hell but only up into the point they
start focusing on opening the doors how
are they dodging the fire then I shall
inform the great mothers that it's time
time for what you should have left the
moment Morgan informed you the cargo was
loaded I don't understand why you've
been waiting around for the Jedi to
catch up aside from the script needing
to give our heroes a way to almost win
forgive me for being crude but why can't
we chop some more heads off or even
hands they're not sparing any lives here
they definitely intend on killing these
guys so why not make it quick and
definitive why are we going for all
these slashing and grazing shots as if
we're showing this on the Disney chant
[Music]
oh we interrupt this episode of Ahsoka
to bring you Hocus Pocus a Star Wars
story zombies Star Wars now has zombies
right this ever happened before no this
is new no it isn't Stormtroopers have
always basically been zombies faceless
fodder that mindlessly attacks and mask
to give the good guys something to shoot
at this is just Star Wars finally
admitting it the
door destroying a door panel makes the
door react exactly as you needed to
cliche still not a sex thing still not a
sex thing still not a sex thing the
storming dead were stumped by a door
which actually makes sense considering
they're zombies and all what's confusing
is that they've somehow retained enough
intelligence to precisely set up
explosives along the store to blow it up
go on I'll handle this we stay together
Remember come on Sabine that [__]
didn't work on seedos and it clearly
doesn't apply here just separate like
you always do until consequences throw
you back together yoshimitsu's mom was
sent down by thrawn to stop the Jedi
from getting onto the ship not just
Ahsoka the Jedi why is she just happily
letting Ezra and saine go wait a second
what's going on here first we have an
intelligent villain and now we have a
still camera watching two characters
fight for 10 whole seconds Star Wars I
don't recognize you anymore and I kind
of love
it these Troopers playing hide and seek
instead of using this Advantage at all
shouldn't these Mandalorian helmets have
a chin strap on them or a buckle or
something if your opponent can just take
that off midf fight I don't think it's
helme thing efficiently so means
lightsaber falls off of her hip because
it knows she'll appreciate the victory
so much more if she really has to work
for it oh good that's what I came here
to see hand toand combat between a Jedi
who just built a new lightsaber and a
zombie with a strange level of hand eye
coordination Theus Stakes could not be
higher Ezra Waits until now to force
grab the lightsaber because he either
likes getting his ass thrown around or
wanted a bean to grab hers first because
he didn't want to make her feel
inadequate you can't make that jump yes
you can I appreciate the confence I push
you first and you pull me across just a
second now Sabine I mean congrats you
managed to pick up your lightsaber using
the force but but even that was a
struggle now you're saying with
confidence that you can help throw Ezra
through a force jump uphill across this
huge gap she pulls this off I have
questions about why Luke and Yoda
wereing around on deab so much there's
no time come on oh you we know Sabine is
an abandoning Ahsoka the only thing
leaving this fight is my suspension of
disbelief as I'm now left wondering what
the she's doing for the next minute or
so while Ahsoka is getting her ass
kicked and lightsaber destroyed the
Stormtrooper suddenly decide that
dealing with the Jedi scum is a
spectator sport and they aren't
qualified to participate and you will
die
here alone not alone if eleth hadn't
tagged her in with that epic setup would
Sabina have ever joined the fight was
she really just standing there waiting
for a witty oneliner also I guess not a
single one of these Troopers who are
literally surrounding this place saw sa
Bean get into position to deliver this
line Jedi tummy tucks are brutal would
not recommend also I guess the sword
Isn't So Special after all and can be
used by anyone who picks it up much like
Anakin Elizabeth didn't have to
sacrifice her pupils after
all heroes jump into a seeming Abyss
only to be picked up by a flying
companion cliche why did Thon ship
continue to shoot the Fortress instead
of changing targets to Ahsoka ship I
mean it's kind of comforting to have the
villain back to making questionable
decisions but it's still getting dinged
long live the
Empire this dude really got to give an
entire villain monologue shortly before
jumping away without any consequences
whatsoever now that feels like a
[Music]
cartoon this bird in the nonsense
metaphor it flew in on giving us barely
30 seconds of bail and instead of the 30
minutes I reasonably demanded at the top
of this video I know the show's trying
to set up a cute reveal for Ezra but in
what Universe would they allow an
unknown ship to land and not open fire
Upon A person wearing the enemy's armor
and in reality Ezra's ship got blown up
on approach and he's a force ghost by
now also the episode decides to give us
thrawn and Prejudice in Zombies instead
of Ezra's presumably epic escape from
thon's Star Destroyer I did well did I
thrawn got away Ezra got home and all it
cost was stranding two of his closest
friends in the same place he's been
stranded and the return of the last and
most deadly Imperial warlord I haven't
seen a trade this unbalance since I
swapped my shiny charizard for a packet
of jelly beans I was hungry Ezra is
where he needs to be and so are we by
that logic what was the point of even
trying if we're all going to end up
where we're supposed to be I may as well
just stay on the sofa watching Star Wars
all day which is totally different from
what I'm doing now of course it's
time to move on thing everyone keeps
telling Dave filon about the Clone War
somehow makes it into the script I hope
when I'm a ghost I get to come back to a
point in my life before I've killed a
bunch of younglings and caused Decades
of pain across an entire galaxy
what are you do what are you doing are
you sure you speak well I'm calling
their
Bluff that last
hand nearly killed me there are three
things I love in this
world K
manag small dimples just above a woman
buttocks beautiful features and the fear
in a man's eye who knows I'm about to
hurt
him F you just pick it up already what
was this place an ancient temple built
by my ancestors the night sister of
dapia you're a wizard Harry hello Huang
still in one piece same man new face
well new everything so where do you call
home these days the ship serves me fine
that's it's your home are you too good
for your home answer me you know if Joey
and Chandler walked in right now we
could make a fortune this isn't just
about finding
Ezra it's about being on TV I know that
I for one am very excited to work with
you guys to get into the Octan Tower
find the kagle and put this thing on the
thing would you like to see
it well as long as this not something
weird she quit on me I wish I knew how
to quit you
see she doesn't want me back she wasn't
even thinking about me why don't you
stop winging and cheer the [__] up the
only time you are wasting is your own
take your sword run me through she
wasn't even thinking about me to be fair
to be fair to be fair be
fa forgot how annoying you
are
no capes I'm ready new haircut same dead
arm take us
out number
one unfortunately I won't be joining you
for this one and neither will the
fleet what say what again all com
Transmissions are being Jed we're in
conversation anyway W I got one great
don't get
cocky if I had to guess I would say it
is some sort of hyperspace ring or n
ring there they are they're listing
lazily to the left go left left work
fast I'm going up there she going to do
what there is a colonial woman on the
wing I see
her go go go we're not H come in home
one this is fulker repeat do you read us
over and did I catch a Niner in there
were you're calling from a walkie-talkie
is that a note of fear in your voice I'm
afraid I've always been afraid
we better get moving together less
sarcasm a little more focused
no it's not that knif that's a I'll try
spinning that's a good trick oh no you
did not shoot that green at me
spin don't you hear it you think the
wind is ever trying to tell us something
and we don't know how to hear it anymore
he was a man who loved the
outdoors and
bowling I wonder which of your friends
I'll have you annihilate first
Katra she's mean that'll do that'll do
donkey that'll do Dave's not here man
perhaps you have a story for me and they
say Phil kti calmly walked to the
groundskeeper Shack found a machete
chopped those staff members into 100
pieces and they say he took that same
machete chopped his own off I was hoping
for a room with a view I was hoping
you'd be hoping Ken is invulnerable a
100 men could not fight Chad this is
Elon Musk it's also quite possible that
your friend is dead if you survived I'm
sure he's doing just fine are you the
legal guardian of John Connor and not
your V Riders well you didn't exactly
tell any of us where you were going I
was going kind of for a refugee Motif
you know fleeing my homeland kind of
thing the City of Townsville is under
attack as a first point of order I'd
like to ask that the opposing council's
motion to compel production of The
defendant's Client List be rejected as
it's not relevant to the litigation
who's this [__] the court cannot
admit evidence of this kind from a mere
Droid you call me a Mindless philosopher
you overweight glob of Grease get along
little buggies get out of my way sounds
to me like someone's trapped inside
life's most complicated shape a love
triangle you do you want some myce scam
so bad we don't have
any run away run it is for the
empire the security of our galaxy you're
my boy blue you're my boy
[Music]
blue
mum
MN
the Star Wars holiday
special starring Mark Hamill as Luke
[Music]
Skywalker finish
her
[Music]
[Applause]
fatality
[Music]
any zombies out there don't say that
what that what that the dead word don't
say it why not because it's
[Applause]
[Music]
ridiculous over the hills and far
away tet tubers come to
play have this R they make get on board
the ship ship which would be
problematic we require a little more
time I don't want to go